they're gonna be so many comparisons to
Bohemian Rhapsody with this just warning
you it's gonna get exhausting Rocketman
dananananana recommends the biopic about
Elton John Elton John's played by Tarun
Edgerton who does a great job and this
shows the life and career of Elton John
the highs the lows until about 1990
that's what people want to see with
something like this you know we know the
career but very rarely do we get to see
behind the scenes a peek behind the
curtain so to speak it's a biopic so I
don't know how much if it's [ __ ]
example one of his music producers in
this movie well-known music producer
whose name I don't actually know because
I don't know a lot of music producers
names but I guess his son in real life
isn't happy about how they portrayed him
in this movies I don't know the truth
all I know is I really dug this movie
first of all Taran Edgerton is amazing
in this movie he's so good this movie
starts out with him telling the story of
his life so when he's a kid then he gets
to be Taron Egerton
the energy he brings immediately you're
like oh he's gonna crush it is Elton
John I was gonna say he's the kind of
person who just brightens up a room
you've heard that phrase before right
what does people mean as they brighten
up the room when they're happy but those
kind of people also darken a room when
they're not that's what Taron Egerton
really brings but he brings that energy
that totally brightens up a room when
he's happy and lively well when he's out
of low you can tell he just changes the
mood in the room I know people like that
to just their energy they give it off to
other people the supporting characters
were great too so easy to be like Taron
Egerton and everyone who says that it's
totally right about it but the
supporting characters actually stood out
like Jamie Bell is his best friend right
down to the guy who owns the LA club
that they played at is this eccentric
dude yeah he cracked me up I'll sort of
like the musical numbers in this movie I
didn't know this movie would have
musical numbers like a musical like it's
a play or something he uses Elton John
music a song-and-dance number of
a-tearin editing who I guess actually
sung the music again impressive but it's
used for a transition to basically give
you a lot of information in a very short
amount of time example this one part
where he's like oh I have a lot of money
now to what do I spend it on things so
it's a musical number of him buying
stuff but it goes by so fast instead of
just showing a montage of him buying
stuff you get a really cool song and
dance number with it I just really dug
how they used the musical numbers in
here the thing that this movie does do
that a lot of biopics do is the fact
that it's hard to tell the passage of
time I don't know if it's been months or
years and someone will be like I've been
you for years I'm like I guess it's been
years how many three five what are the
years and it being a peek behind the
curtain a biopic of a famous artist a
famous rock artist I feel like this
theme isn't all of them there's always
some music producer type who's a scumbag
and there's usually a bender of drugs
alcohol and/or depression that's also in
here and that's why I appreciate these
biopics I appreciate this one because
the natural way to think is their famous
what have they got to be depressed about
why are they down there shouldn't catch
me by surprise anymore but it's like it
always does it did this time and it will
continue to do so I go into this musical
icon biopics not actually knowing I'm
going in to watch a tragedy a tragedy
about someone who becomes a musical icon
and a multi-millionaire tragedy but it's
real money is not everything and it does
not buy happiness cuz in the end
Rocketman was a proper rock biopic you
see how musically gifted he was as a
child you see the problems that came
along with his childhood that he carried
into his adulthood and once again we
find out that rock Fame or fame in
general isn't all it's cracked up to be
like there's some great stuff there I'm
sure we'd all love a piece of it but the
brighter the bright the darker the dark
that's just the way it is and this
properly Illustrated that I had some
great music too boots I'll say rocket
man's definitely worth watching and
definitely worth buying on blu-ray made
it through without one Bohemian Rhapsody
comparison all right so Rocket Man have
you seen it what did you think of it or
what's a musical biopic or a biopic
about a famous person in general that
you would like to see whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]